leur redonnant toi alors seulement je
trouve très bien très content ouais bon
disque platine
ouais quasiment ça c'est comme à la télé
le mec arrive on lui dit qu'il vend
beaucoup de discours est le single est
classé au top 50 aussi ouais t'as pas
l'air content merci je suis content de
toi quand tu donnes un peu de mal
finalement quand tu fais un peu le tour
des médias
oui tu vois que ça marche c'est pas
compliqué que ça avait bien marché aussi
sans faire le tour des médias
enfin tout fait remarquer sion promo ils
n'ont pas appris - ouais ils ont pas mal
de toi je suis a fait 3 télé ça fait
plein de télé ensuite a vraiment donné
du mal tu as fait martin ouais ça fait
bravo
ouais t'as fait drucker je fais kabbaj
tafer elkabbach a tout fait et toi
qu'elle lui meilleur souvenir de cette
promo à part ce soir bien sûr de cette
tournée de promo c'est martin j'ai fait
aussi le journal défaire 3 avec pour la
marque
juste de 8h - et - 2 à 8 heures après il
ya la classe bac
bah oui c'était c'était short comme siné
bien et qu'elle était le pire souvenir
je me sens à tous le pire souvenir c'est
la presse écrite mois ouais bah ouais
c'est grave je passe des heures à
raconter ta vie à ces gens là des coups
qui posent des questions et ou puis
après tu lis ça qui est utile mais c'est
pas vrai c'est mon sosie qui a fait
l'interview n'est pas la même chose du
tout pas vraiment toi qui avais dis ce
que j'ai à dire c'est dans mes chansons
ont en fait c'est pas vrai les gens ils
veulent te voir la td de l'écouter
parler ils en ont pas marre mme banon
maintenant on est content qu'il soit là
avant alors dans les hauts risques par
les le politique à la con et où sa prise
de position
dis-moi marchand de cailloux marchand de
sable alors s'était vu comment cette
idée
le marchand de cailloux dans le marchand
de sable c'est pour endormir les petits
enfants et le marchand de cailloux c'est
pourrait réveiller tels vols si je dis
bien c'est la deuxième fois qu'il dit
mais tu as dit vachement bien c'est sur
l'intifada cette chanson non pas
seulement c'est surtout les endroits du
monde où il ya les mômes qui jettent des
cailloux aux soldats cui qui leur tirent
dessus à balles et en irlande alors oui
peut être du nord ce matin à
johannesburg
ça peut être à vous en veulent un voile
à cette chanson une chanson sur ton donc
pas très très sympa quand même pas très
très méchante n'ont plus vraiment se
trouve inscrit
quand tu dis tout voir la gloire qui
s'en va et où c'est pas terrible je suis
regardé les chiffres et sondages en fait
est le plus connu des déçus du
socialisme toi sinon je suis peut-être
pas le plus déçu je suis plus connu
telle plus connue des déçus et une
chanson sur la corrida aussi oui j'aime
pas du tout la corrida tu parles des
pétasses qui pose la rue pour la garenne
nîmoise c'était à revers la corrida que
j'aime pas que c'est vrai j'aime pas
trop mais la chanson traite plus d'une
public féminin de la corrida les
parisiennes à la noble parisianisme
snobisme quand même tout ce qui tourne
autour
j'avais pas envie de faire une chanson
l'éternel débat pour ou contre la
corrida d'un côté les aficionados avec
leur leur culture leurs traditions leurs
arguments historiques presque religieuse
pour expliquer la beauté de la corrida
l'autre côté les zoophiles
je prends même si depuis lors non mais
c'est vrai donc l'ampleur ni dans
l'autre
tu voulais parler dans des aspects de la
corrida je trouve grotesque candidat
c'est un spectacle qui ne plaît pas
parce que c'est un spectacle de violence
avec une la mort d'un animal mais je
trouve pas plus ignoble que les infos de
20 heures la différence c'est que quand
on m'a quand on bombarde bagdad
l'étape à 3000 colas quatre lots disent
quoi il ya une chanson sur le
paris-dakar aussi relaté pu l'écrire
avant que ce soit paris le cas parce que
tu dis 500 commerces sur la ligne de
départ du paris dakar et maintenant pire
que tu ouvres aux caps à lui tenir mais
seulement quand même bah ouais je
croyais qu'il allait bien finir par
crever de leur belle mort les gens
n'avaient plus rien à [ __ ] de leur
connaît et que ça commençait à fatiguer
tout le monde et puis là il rallonge le
parcours ils prennent tous continuer à
traverser des des légitimiser des
régimes ignobles comme la libye ou
continuer à faire de l'afrique une cour
de récréation mais la libye sans
scrupules l'afrique du sud ils ont dit
voilà une chanson j'ai cru reconnaître
nova non c'était pas lui du tout un bon
j'avais une rime jeu c'est l'histoire
d'un mec il essaie de placer ses
chansons à droite et à gauche personne
en veut à la fin ils se retrouvent non
c'est moi le mec je me retrouvais qu'une
chanson craignos je cherche une rime
jeudi vont créer une chanson créée dios
roland garros je prends un blaireau qui
sort de roland garros je suis dit tu es
beau et et qu'on va faire de toi un
petit chanteur à la con pour faire un
succès des théâtres une chanson shakhter
éphémère mecs qui font les tubes de
l'été quoi les chanteurs d'un d'un slot
j'arrive au québec il ya quelques mois
là et tu te mets que dia est bien à ton
dernier disque et thoune et son bambin
belle y en a une seule touche parlerons
qu'est ce que tu lis mes actes à yannick
noah
je crois qu'ils vont y passer alors en
garros est un chanteur faisait le plein
d'eau qui est numéro 1 tout l'été
ensuite on m'a demandé à de parler dit
yannick noah est ce que je pense et lui
comme une con artist est à dire on sait
pas s'il chante pour orangina ou pour la
pomme compte pas y avait une certaine
confusion dans ces chansons là c'est
l'espèce de son espèce de lambada un
coup envoyé
non c'est vrai sa chanson un peu third
world music toi world music tu vois
africaine sud-africaine zoulou et puis à
côté il y avait les pubs pour la même
chanson qui servait pour une pub pour
les mars où les lions bounty les lions
les lions alors ça fait un peu confusion
tout ça on va aller la télé maintenant
qu'on a parlé de ton disque a suivi la
sphère bilalian mardi soir là tu en
penses quoi toi je pense qu'il fait les
vidéos et ouais quand tu la raison mais
par gomis pour direct où les mecs qui
font de la propagande pour le fascisme
et le nazisme sous couvert de faire de
l'information dans la fougue d'antan des
idées à gervais faut pas laisser
s'exprimer c'est vrai la fin pour deux
ils s'expriment déjà tout seul dans la
vie quotidienne dans la rue donc pas de
liberté pour les ennemis de la liberté
mais ils sont libres mais qu'on les
invite pas à la télé en dix ans ensemble
en le jouant les vierges effarouchées
après en tant choqué est tous passé mais
qu'il pallie c'est pas de la théorie
c'est pas d'idéologie cesser de laisser
le vomissent qui balance mais quand j'ai
entendu parler ces gens là j'ai envie de
leur dire particules quand tu pètes
et la chaîne musicale alors parce que la
dernière fois que tu en as entendu
parler 188 mitterrand avait invité à
l'elysée pour en parler
et tu t'étais dit quand il y est elle
est où il va se représenter le vieux
parce que quand il commence à voir des
artistes pour leur parler de la chaîne
musicale c'est que l'électorat jeune ça
le temps il était réélu il ya du jour
pas la même musique à l'invaincu ces
déçus la belle se cache pas que
franchement paraît que c'est important
pour la création tout culture pour la
musique et pour les jeunes créateurs à
tous moi les chaînes de télé je trouve
cela franchement beaucoup trop déjà je
veux dire c'est pas mon cheval de
bataille
mais la chaîne busan causes perdues
justement est ce que tu te rends compte
des fonds dont 25 par exemple tout ce
que tu auras envie de la défendre cette
chaîne qui les rend tout kiss-in plein
de bêtises et je ne défends pas tous
défendre les plus faibles